Halloween used to be my favorite holiday
a time of the year where you could dress
up as someone else and have fun without
being judged but as you get older those
times a few and far if you're reading or
listening to this this is not a joke the
trashman is real we summoned him and our
lives will never be the same
I've never shared what really happened
that night of anyone but maybe our
experiences will stop others making the
same mistake the story begins a few
years ago with a video a video that this
rather stupid and irresponsible youtuber
thought would be funny The Legend of the
trash man Lovecraft's undiscovered work
a seemingly harmless April Fool's joke
pretending the trash man had some kind
of secret law and wasn't just part of a
TV show a story about a homeless man
down on his luck killed by a gang of
thieves over a cup of coffee except he
didn't die he encountered an entity that
resurrected him as the king of trash
destined to bring with him the trash
pocalypse and the end of the world I'll
admit at the time it was pretty funny
but this is the Internet
you can't just make a joke and expect
everyone to understand that it's not
real in a matter of weeks brain nuts and
Mongoloids all over the world started
cults in the trash man's name every
Starbucks was flooded with people
desperate for a venti sugar-free nonfat
vanilla soy double shaunt decaf no foam
extra hot peppermint white chocolate
mocha of light with an extra syrup just
so they could get a taste of their new
Lord and saviors favorite beverage worst
of all the trash man had been thrust
into the mainstream numerous rituals and
incantations that could summon the
trashman circulated the Internet reddit
4chan Facebook Twitter it was everywhere
of course the Instagram models and
influencer leeches pounced on the chance
to sell diet plans and workouts inspired
and certified by the trashman you can
finally have that beach body you've
always deserved just stop recycling and
inhale trash
you can smell the weight loss the twitch
streamers and youtubers had their trash
flavored G fuel which contained real
authentic trash use code trash to get
15% of your order today I even heard
that Netflix are making a trash man
movie where the trash man was being
played by none other than brie Larson
because her acting is truly trash I'm
sure you're starting to get my point the
world had gone trash crazy but just like
all fads it eventually died down when
people realize that the rituals were
fake and it was nothing more than an
April Fool's prank turned into a giant
cash grab it became another irrelevant
trend destined to die even the guy who
made the video in the first place
disappeared some say he was taken by the
trash man to his underground city
whereas others say he just went back to
making regular mythology videos no one
really knows because YouTube
notifications are trash anyway I digress
now that you have an idea of what
started everything I'll continue with my
story I was in my senior year at college
and come October I had some time off to
study but that was the last thing I
wanted to do so I decided to head back
home and visit my friends for Halloween
if anyone enjoyed the holiday as much as
I did it was them they'd always have a
massive party every year but that kind
of stopped when we all went off to
college and did our own things I got
there about a week early just the CSUN
family I grew up in southern
Philadelphia so MIT wasn't that far away
I don't really know why I didn't visit
home more often the day I arrived we
agreed to meet up at our local diner
Frankie's my best friend Zach his
girlfriend Kayleigh and Charley Zack and
Kelly were there on time but Charlie was
running late as usual so we ordered
without him as usual we spoke for a
while and it seemed as if nothing had
really changed from the last time they
were both happy together with jobs they
enjoyed and a bunch of holidays planned
you know couple things
I was pretty focused on school and
Charlie from the sound of it was now
working part-time in a thrift store
about an hour in when we were getting
ready to leave Charlie came bundling
through the door with that grin on his
face
the same grin that always indicated he
had something stupid plan he slid into
our booth and slammed down an old beaten
up book on the table you guys know what
that is no charlie but I'm sure you're
gonna tell us we all humored him that my
fellow worms is the Necronomicon as in
Lovecraft's Necronomicon Kaley seemed
more interested in Zack and I did yeah
damn right that's the one some guy in a
suit and shades dropped it off today at
the store when I asked him how much he
wanted for it the idiot just walked away
and what do you plan on doing with it
Zack intervened using it obviously look
at all these rituals there's even one
for the trash man this has to be the
real deal you're still obsessed of
finding the trash man even after all
this time we're not all resting just get
up and leave and go work for NASA maybe
this is my shot at being someone Zack
and Kaley didn't seem too bothered like
they'd heard this story before my place
tonight and we can go over what's inside
and see if it's real we'll be there and
Kelly answered for them both Charlie
turned to me waiting for an answer no
sounds like a waste of time come on what
happened to Dennis the Menace you
remember with a crazy ship we did when
we were younger first of all no one ever
called me that and we're not kids
anymore
sounds like MIT has made Dennis the
Menace a real Grouch one last adventure
before you forget us all I remembered I
was there to have fun fine
let's do it and just like that Dennis
the Menace is back stop calling me that
Charlie darted out of the booth are you
not gonna order anything does that
question him no time I have to prepare
for what the rituals there's more to
them than just reciting some mumbo jumbo
I told you guys this is the real deal
and just like that he was gone good to
see Charlie is still Charlie the last
few years have been pretty tough on him
and we haven't exactly been great
friends
Charlie had lost his mother a few years
ago the only family he had and we all
went off to college he had this crazy
idea that if he could find the trash man
he could bring her back and none of us
really had the heart to tell him how
insane that sounded he doesn't still
think that he can bring he does we've
tried to help him but it always just
ends up back at the trash man I think
it's the only thing that keeps him going
we didn't say much after that the three
of us just sat there in silence I guess
we felt the same guilt for allowing
Charlie to get this bad for being such
shitty friends
when I got to Charlie's house I felt
uneasy I don't know if it was the
weather or the fact I hadn't been back
there since his mother passed away
Charlie greeted me at the door before I
could even knock well now look who's
late the power's out by the way so grab
a candle and follow me were almost ready
I followed Charlie down to the basement
where Zack and Kaley were waiting around
a candle lit table
Charlie's basement was more of a bomb
shelter
his mother was convinced that the end
was coming and when it did she would be
prepared
so I guess insanity runs in the family
remind me again why we're doing this in
the basement
in the dark during a storm just like
every horror movie we've ever seen if
you don't think it's real then why does
it even matter I couldn't disagree with
Charlie there I didn't believe in any of
this and after all this night was for
him so I took a seat of the others who
looked equally as confused as I did you
can take a look inside the book and
while I get everything ready I looked
over at Zack you thinking the covers
really made out of human skin no idea
but I ain't touch in there stop being
babies it's just leather Kaley flipped
over the cover landing on a random page
the summoning of the Damon and the
summoning of the Night Man
they both looked over at me looks like
garbage to me she turned the page more
incoherent symbols some language I'd
never seen and a bunch of grotesque
pictures this is pretty weird but it's
also pretty awesome
Zack noted an agreement but I still
couldn't shake that feeling from earlier
the secrets of ROM ham look at
everything it makes love potion
transmutation box everlasting youth
elixir grow your own Magnum dong
whatever that means
we should definitely test some of this
stuff Kaylee seemed pretty sold already
and I'd be lying if I said it didn't
interest me
Charlie's been gone for let us begin
maggots charlie slammed down a tree
before Zach could finish what the hell
is that this Dennis is all the
ingredients we need to summon the trash
man we each took a Starbucks cup from
Charlie drink up and we can begin the
ritual
I'm not drinking anything until you tell
us what's inside of it
it's a venti sugar-free nonfat vanilla
soy double short decaf no foam extra hot
peppermint white chocolate mocha of
light whip a nectar syrup obviously and
what else
it smells like sewage it's better if you
drink up first without a second thought
was act down the entire camp shortly
followed by Charlie and Kaylee who by
the lips and their faces didn't seem too
bothered I wasn't gonna be the only one
who was down I closed my eyes pinched my
nose and went to my happy place whatever
it was it was thick lumpy and watery all
at the same time i gagged once or twice
but it went down when I opened my eyes
all three of them were throwing up into
a cauldron like a bowl they wiped
themselves off and turned to face me as
if it was my turn you have to throw up
in the bowl Charlie explained as if it
was obvious I don't need to I'm good the
entire ritual won't work if you don't
I'm not sticking my fingers down my
throat just continue you know you were
right
it smelt like sewage because one of the
main ingredients was sewer water what
else did you put inside Kaylee inquired
looking like she was ready to blow her
top well whatever was on the list you
know Apple skin hand sanitizer glue
spray paint sewage rat meat and
hard-boiled eggs all blended up and
added to some coffee oh and the secret
ingredient Charlie lifted up his
sockless feet and wiggled his toes
freshly cut toenails that was enough for
me to begin hurling into the cauldron
you made us string that Kaylie stone
suggests that she wasn't so interested
in the book anymore yes I knew we were
going to throw up so it's not really
dangerous is it
you made us drink your [ __ ] toenails
Charlie Zack chimed in looking as peeved
as Kaylee and I I cut my toenails a few
weeks ago but the homeless guy across
the street did sell me his own personal
collection
they weren't freshly cut and that just
adds more character just when I thought
I was done I found myself face first in
that bowl again throwing up whatever was
left over from the first time once
everyone had calmed down
we continued Charlie grab the book and
turned to a page of a man on a throne of
trash you ready we all nodded in the
least convincing manner possible he
closed his eyes throw up his hood and
stirred whatever was in that bowl and
then it began Charlie was a lot of
things a weirdo [ __ ] disgusting and
more than just slightly crazy but he was
also a showman in the house of trash the
King lays dormant in his palace of
garbage he awaits in the rivers of
sewage he stands monster dong in hand
please o mighty and well-endowed trash
man accept this gift of sewer soup made
only with the finest toenail clippings
we ask only for an audience with the
Lord of trash and in exchange our soul
was you can take wait a second
I didn't such Charlie hushed away any
concerns from Zack and continued I take
this holy creature and with it I give
you a piece of myself he dangled a dead
rat in the air before dropping it and
spitting into the bowl we sat there in
silence waiting
after ten minutes I had had enough well
that was great now I'm gonna go find
some mouthwash and probably net look
Charlie was pointing at the ball it
began to boil once well I checked
underneath for a hot plate but there
wasn't one it's happening I told you it
was the real deal
we were all speechless I don't think any
of us expected anything from this
trainwreck of an idea all of a sudden
the boiling stopped and the rat
resurfaced floating in the gunk I moved
in closer but as I did it sprung to life
leaping out of the bowl and onto the
table it stumbled around for a while
before standing on its hind legs
what are you [ __ ] looking at I guess
this is where the story gets crazy the
voice didn't come from any of us it came
from the rats stood on two legs staring
at me expecting an answer a talking rat
wasn't like at muster out of shock oh
great another 63 IQ human meddling with
things a djembe how did you form
Mongoloids get this book then rats don't
talk
I see it's gonna be one of those days is
it you know if I were human I'd shove my
fist right in your ass hard and fast but
not in a sexual way in the I'm pissed
off sword away a man in the black suit
gave it to me toe guy wears shades looks
like Vin Diesel skinny cousin but you
can actually understand what we say yeah
that's the guy
oh boy the boss isn't opening like this
not one bit the boss you mean the trash
man
Charlie couldn't hide his excitement
yeah a new idiot summoned him when he's
got important business to take care of
he will not be pleased so he is coming
then unfortunately for you yes and the
rat left off a table and onto the floor
the names cricket by the way not rat but
you'll be joining me soon anyway except
you it pointed at me and gave me the
finger
[ __ ] you [ __ ] that was the last
thing it said before disappearing into
the floorboards Charlie was ecstatic
running around the room fist pumping and
screaming the rest of us was still
confused did we drink sewage reanimate a
talking rat who then proceeded to insult
you and talk about fisting you ya think
we did
I'm glad Zach finish my sentence because
it sounded ridiculous what do you think
he meant when he said we'd be joining
him soon
I don't know Kayleigh it's a [ __ ]
talking rat none of this makes any sense
it does I trained in whatever we drank
was obviously spiked or laced or
something the entire thing was just a
hallucination I tried desperately to
find some kind of rational explanation a
hallucination that we all saw Kayleigh
was as unconvinced as I was it's late
we're all confused and were all tired
and I've personally had enough talking
rats and toenails for a lifetime let's
just go home
that was the most rational thing I had
heard all evening and that's what we did
the next few days were surprisingly
quiet we were all on edge except for
Charlie who was eagerly awaiting our
visit from the trash man as the days
when buying Charlie grew more and more
frustrated whereas the rest of us were
just relieved it was all [ __ ]
Halloween came and so did the party I'd
forgotten about it was at Charlie's
place which made sense considering he
didn't care what kind of mess was left
behind honestly I didn't want to go but
I had already bought my costume well it
wasn't much of a costume I was going as
James Bond the suit I already had so I
just ordered the bowtie in a toy gun I
was running late that night because I
couldn't get my bowtie straight and my
OCD just wouldn't let me go nice suit
you got there [ __ ] oh I turned to my
right and sitting on the basin was the
same rat from that night
you're not real piss off
I had hoped if I said it out loud it
might be true I'm about as real with
your gaping anus when I am done with it
because if I was human again I'd shout
yeah yeah I get it you'd shove that face
right in my ass hard and fast but not in
a sexual way year weirdo you summoned me
enough of that attitude unless you what
do you want nothing I'm just here to
enjoy your last night of course because
the trash man is coming to get me Oh No
yeah yeah everybody's a tough guy in
today that a fist in their anus that's
not something people say you just made
that up of course an uncultured swine
and a simpleton like you would think
that well you meant to be anyway a
smartly dressed [ __ ] no I'm James Bond
the only thing you and double-oh-seven
have in common is that how many brain
cells you got floating around your tiny
human peanut brain
I had had about enough of this rat
insulting me I reach for my can of
deodorant but as I turned to spray he
was gone I thought about calling the
others and telling them what I'd seen
but it was Halloween I needed a break
and I needed to have some fun and I
wasn't gonna let some anus obsessed
talking rat ruin that for me I was late
and I was pissed off but I was going to
that party trash man or not when I
arrived it was pretty much what I
expected a bunch of drunk 20-somethings
trying their hardest to forget that they
were now adults with responsibilities it
was every college party you'd ever seen
but in fancy dress so I guess that made
it a tad more bearable people were
dancing drinking shouting and stumbling
all over the place I went to school with
most of these people but they seemed
like strangers I wondered what they were
doing now what life choices they made
and whether they were truly happy
because they seemed happier than me I
bumped into Zach before I get too deep
into my own head you're late yeah long
story well Charlie has officially lost
it what's he done now
see for yourself I followed him to the
kitchen where Charlie was jumping on the
counter there were chants of rum ham rum
ham Charlie had a ham on a stick which
he was dousing in rum
he took a lighter and set the home on
fire rum ham for you my lord
he thinks the trashman is coming to his
party
is that good see I wasn't as dismissive
as he was what are you not telling me
well the talking rat paid me a visit
today he smirked he came back to give
you that fist thing after all no well
kind of but he said the trash man was
coming tonight the smirk on his face
quickly disappeared where's Kaylee I
don't know we came here together but I
haven't seen her in the past hour you
don't think she's in trouble I don't
know give her a call I scoured the room
but there was no sign of her what I did
find was worse up and down the skirting
boards and stairs there were rats two
lanes of them some coming and some going
there was one at the front door looking
at me giving me the finger I guess that
was cricket a turn to Zac who shook his
head Cayley was an answering I showed
him the rats and we decided to follow
them upstairs Charlies place was huge
but if she was here we'd find her the
trail led us to the bathroom both of us
knew what could be on the other side of
that door but it didn't matter
Zac nudge it open and we forced
ourselves in I'm not sure what I was
expecting but it wasn't what we found
there in front of us was Kaylee at least
part of her she was inside the toilet we
couldn't see her lower half but her
upper half was trying desperately to
pull herself out hello boys I've been
waiting
you must be Zachary and this lest an
impressive specimen I take it is Dennis
the Mandan introduced himself he didn't
have to we knew who he was
after all we summoned him Kaylee was
still struggling and calling out for
help
silence the trash man snapped his
fingers in her mouth filled of
hard-boiled eggs so why have I been
summoned here again Zack and I could
muster no word what's the matter
rat got your tongue cat he moved closer
to Zack what I believe it's cat got your
tongue not rat incorrect rats are
superior to cats in every way that's not
what I said I don't care what you said
this toilet appears to be backed up
shall we give it a flush he snapped his
fingers again and the toilet began to
swell we watched as Kaylee span round
and around before completely
disappearing Zack was far more animated
than I was where did you send her
to my kingdom bring her back now no well
you're welcome to join her Zak turned to
me as if I had the answer I just shook
my head you'll never see her again it's
your choice
Zachary come with me and be with her
forever or stay here with this useless
turd I'm sorry did I have to find her
I'd like to think I would have done the
same in Zach's position but I'm no hero
okay I'll go
excellent choice you will make a fine
trash monkey he snapped his fingers once
more and the Starbucks cup appeared in
his hand drink and you shall join your
lab what is it it's what you drank in
order to summon me only more authentic
Zach took a swig and began to choke he
dropped to his knees and started
convulsing I looked to the trash man but
he just laughed another trash monkey to
add to the collection ah when I look
back at Zach he was gone his clothing
was in a pile on the floor but he was
nowhere to be seen a small rat crawled
out from his trouser leg the trash man
picked it up and down with it over the
toilet say goodbye to your friend he's
going to a happier place I probably
should have been more concerned about
seeing two of my best friends being
flushed down a toilet but none of this
made sense how do you flush a person
down a toilet
magic of course this Denis is why you
are not ready to join us you do not
believe I only accept the finest misfits
those who have no dreams no aspirations
those who society is beat down upon
because they do not conform you are not
of the finest you are of the worst you
still think a high-paying job makes you
better than others you think a high
social standing will make them respect
you and better yet you think it will
make you happy the worst part of all of
this was nothing he said was untrue the
bathroom door opened and charlie wobbled
in clearly intoxicated Dennis did I ever
tell you he paused when he saw the trash
man hey trash man and I knew you were
real you are most certainly of the
finest hair oh thank you thank you come
with me to trash topia Charlie a place
where you will finally feel at home a
place where rivers of coffee flow
endlessly where hookers and blow a
mandatory and where we feast on rum
hammer every night that sounds good but
can you bring back my mum first there is
no need she's already waiting for us Wow
okay I'm in
I watched him repeat the same process as
Zack but Charlie obviously enjoyed the
drink with rat Charlie in Han the trash
man gave me his final speech you will
see your friends eventually you're still
full of hope you want to put people on
Mars you want a wife and a family but I
will make sure you have none of that
so go ahead finish school get your dream
job meet a nice girl just when you think
all of the hard work is finally paying
off I will return and take it all I will
reach my fist deep inside of your anus
and I will take everything why what did
I ever do because I'm the trash man I
come out I throw trash all over there
all over the ring and then I start
eating garbage and then I pick up the
trash can and I bashed a guy over the
head that doesn't answer my question
it doesn't even make sense he gave me
the finger before jumping into the
toilet and disappearing with Charlie the
police never found any of them just a
bunch of kids gone missing after getting
drunk I never did finish college I
dropped out when I was institutionalized
ironically there isn't much left for the
trash man to take you'd be surprised how
many people in these places aren't
actually crazy but their stories just
like mine are dismissed as the ramblings
of a lunatic every Halloween I can feel
his presence a pulsating feeling in my
anus this year feels like it might be
the last